The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
ocw.mit.edu.
IAIN STEWART: All right,
that's roughly where we were.
So last time, we started
talking about SCET.
We said it's going
to be a theory that
can describe energetic
hadrons and energetic jets.
Our first example was
discussing about a process
with an energetic hadron,
which is this pink pion.
So the pion has a large
momentum, large energy.
It's much bigger
than lambda QCD.
It's much bigger than in m pi.
And it moves basically along
a light cone direction.
So that was a motivation for us
to use light cone coordinates.
So we introduce
an n and an n bar.
And with that n and n bar,
which satisfy n squared 0,
n bar squared 0, and n dot n
bar equals 2 as a normalization
convention, we can
decompose any momentum P
mu in terms of components along
n, components along n bar,
and then the remaining two
components which we call
the perpendicular components.
So we can also write the metric
out in these coordinates.
And this kind of makes
explicit that you
have this off-diagonal
nature to the basis,
that you have n
mu with n bar mu.
So unlike Cartesian
coordinates, where
the component along
a direction is just
given by dotting that
vector into the vector
you start with, here
the component along n
is given by dotting n
bar into the vector.
And that's reflected in the
metric here in the sense
that you have these
terms n within n bar.
So you can do this with any
tensor if you have an epsilon.
You can find an epsilon
perp tensor, for example,
by taking epsilon and
putting in an n bar and an n.
And then this would be
a two-component tensor
that behaves in the
perpendicular direction
as an antisymmetric tensor.
And this g perp mu nu
would be effectively living
in the little subspace
of the perp coordinates.
And again, it's a
metric tensor there.
And this would be the
antisymmetric tensor there.
OK, so these are the
coordinates we're going to use.
So n here had a
physical motivation,
as you saw from my picture.
The pion was moving
in the n direction.
And bar was just
a vector that we
decided that we needed in
order to define things.
So if you have some vector
where n squared is 0
and you want to make a
decomposition of coordinates,
then you're required
to introduce
a complimentary vector,
which is this n bar
to make the decomposition
for the reasons I said.
The simplest choice
that you could make,
if you made this choice
for n, so if we choose n
to be 1, 0, 0,
minus 1, as I did,
then the simplest thing you
could do for n bar is to pick n
bar to be 1, 0, 0, plus 1.
So then that would be
a lightlike vector.
When you dot it into
this vector, you get 2.
And it satisfies all the
criteria that we would need.
If I choose these
two vectors, then I
have to find what
perp is because perp
is the space that's
orthogonal to these vectors.
So that's these two
coordinates, OK?
So perp in general is defined
such that n dot P perp is 0
and n bar dot P perp is 0.
It's the orthogonal
two directions
to the ones that are
picked out by an n bar.
And so you need to know what
n and n bar are in order
to define what perp is.
So this is one choice.
You could make other choices.
And we'll come back
to this later on.
So just by way of example, if
I have the same choice for n,
but I choose n bar
to be 3, 2, 2, 1,
that would also be a
choice that's equally good.
I need this to be minus 1.
I'll do this, make
my choice work.
I guess, well, OK, if
we want the same sign,
then I have to do this.
OK, so 9 minus 8, this
thing still squares to 0.
You dot it, you get
3 minus 1 is 2, OK?
So it still satisfies the
criteria that we had here.
And it points in some
other weird direction.
So the point is that this
is an auxiliary vector,
and there's some freedom
in what you pick for it.
And once you've picked
this, if you pick these two,
you would have a different
definition of perp.
OK.
But it's an equally
valid possible choice.
And we'll actually exploit
this freedom later on.
But for now, we'll mostly focus
on picking the simplest choice.
OK, what we're actually
interested in describing
in these processes
is not just the plan,
but what goes on
inside the plan.
What is the quark level process?
So we're interested
in the constituents.
That's where the dynamics are.
Is there any questions
before I keep going?
No.
So in this process, B to D
pi, if you think about it
in the rest frame
of the B meson,
which is the most natural
frame, then the B meson
we've already learned
how to describe that.
We can describe that with
HQET, same with the D meson.
And we know that the things
that are inside the B and the D
meson are one heavy quark and
then a bunch of soft stuff.
So I'll call these guys soft
because the dynamical part is
soft.
And so we can use HQET
for them as we did before.
And that means we're describing
gluons and quarks that
are inside these hadrons
where the forward momentum are
of order lambda QCD.
The pion, on the other hand,
is what we would collinear.
So as I already described,
the pion's energy
is much greater than its mass.
Its highly boosted.
If you were to talk about
it in the rest frame,
then like the B and the D
meson, then the constituents
of the pion would have
momentum of order lambda QCD.
But if you were to talk about
the pion in the rest frame,
you'd have to talk about the B
and the D in the boosted frame.
So let's stick with
describing the B and the D
in the rest frame or
close to the rest frame.
The B meson is in
its rest frame.
In the D meson is slow.
And in that case, we're stuck
with the pion being energetic.
So in rest frame,
our pion would be--
it would also have
quarks and gluons
our P mu is order lambda QCD.
And we can actually just take
that result, once we know that,
and boost it to another frame.
So let's just boost along
z hat by some kappa that's
much greater than
1 as the boost.
And the way that light
cone coordinates boost
is very simple.
If you're along the axis of
the light cone coordinates,
it's multiplicative.
So P minus gets
enhanced by some amount.
P plus gets suppressed
by the same amount.
That's one nice thing
about these coordinates.
And of course, P perp
doesn't change because it's
perpendicular to the boost.
So now, we can get our
pion, which is moving,
which should be pink.
And if we ask about
its constituents,
we just boost the components
of this for vector.
So we ask about how they scale.
And we look at the
different components.
The plus, minus, and perp
scale differently now,
so we have to break
it up by that.
And if we boost it by
this amount Q or lambda
over Q, Q over
lambda, then that's
the scaling for
this boosted pion.
OK.
So now, it's got a component
in the minus direction.
n bar dot P is
order Q. That's what
we saw before when
we decomposed the P,
that it was basically Q
times a lightlike vector.
But that was the pion.
Now, we're talking about the
constituents inside the pion.
Constituents inside
the pion fill it out.
They fill it out in
the perpendicular
by an amount lambda QCD that's
perpendicular to the direction
of its motion.
And then the plus momentum
got correspondingly smaller
as the minus momentum
have got bigger,
so we have that scaling.
And so the relative
scaling here is
what actually defines
something being collinear.
So the relative
scaling of this vector
here is that the P minus is
much bigger than the P perp is
much bigger than the P plus.
And that's what we
mean by collinear.
It's collimated
in some direction,
and that direction
is the direction
of the large momentum.
You always have
to be careful when
you say things like that
because the component
along the direction is the
opposite lightlike vector,
but I think you'll
always know what I mean.
OK, so in the n mu direction, we
have a large component P minus.
And that defines this
thing is collimated
in a particular direction.
It's perpendicular fluctuations
to that direction are small.
And so all the
degrees of freedom
that are in this boosted pion
have that type of scaling.
So what we're
describing, or what
we want to describe if we
have a field theory for this,
is we want to
describe, if you like,
fluctuations about the
pion momentum, which,
ignoring the pion mass, we could
just take it to be like this.
And the size of the
fluctuations we need to treat
are things that can fluctuate
by amounts of this size.
So the field theory
is going to have
to describe fluctuations about
some kind of canonical scaling.
And the field
theory for this pion
is going to have
to be describing
collinear fluctuations
that are of this type.
Just like the HQET had to
describe soft fluctuations,
P mu's of order lambda QCD
ignorant of the heavy quark
mass, here it's a little
bit more complicated.
But that's the kind of thing
we want the field theory to do.
Any questions about that?
So the way that we write this
is we say that P plus, P minus,
P perp has a particular
scaling that we
call lambda squared
1 lambda where
lambda is some small parameter.
And if we have a momentum
that scales that way,
we call it collinear.
So this is generic any
case with any lambda.
And our allowed here was
just lambda QCD over Q.
But if we encounter
another physical problem
where the lambda
was different, we
would also call that collinear.
All right, so what's a
nice way of picturing this,
what we're doing here?
Because it's a little
bit different than you're
used to with an
effective field theory.
Usually, with an effective
field theory, what you're doing
is you're separating modes
by their invariant mass.
You have things with large
invariant mass, small invariant
mass.
If you think about
massive particles,
well, that's just the
invariant mass squared.
So if you're separating
massive particles
from massless particles
or less massive particles,
you're really separating things
along an invariant mass curve.
Just an invariant mass variable
is used for the separation.
And that doesn't
quite suffice here.
Because as you saw, the pion
in the B and the D meson,
they both had P squared
of order lambda QCD.
What separates the pion
from the B or the D meson
is this morphyne structure.
So SCET is actually an
example of an effective field
theory that requires at
least more than one variable
to describe where the
degrees of freedom live.
So we can draw a picture
for what we've been talking
about here in two variables.
Let's just pick P
minus and P plus.
And essentially, what's
going on in this space is
you can think that there's
degrees of freedom that
live in this space at
different locations.
So out here, if I draw
a hyperbola like this,
then remember that P squared
was P plus times P minus minus P
perp squared.
But let's ignore P perp
squared for this picture.
So if I draw a curve of constant
P squared in this plane, then
it's I hyperbola.
So these are curves
of constant P squared.
And this one here has
P squared of order Q
squared, which might be Mb
squared or some hard scale.
So this any degrees of freedom
that live on this curve,
or in particularly
these ones, would
be what we would call
hard degrees of freedom.
And those are something that
we want to integrate out
of the effective theory.
And the other degrees of freedom
that we've been talking about
have smaller invariant mass.
So this hyperbola down here
has P squared of order lambda
QCD squared.
But there's two different
degrees of freedom
that live on this curve.
One of them has a large P minus.
That's the collinear one,
so it should be pink.
And then the soft
one lives down there.
So P minus here is scaling,
if you like, lambda to the 0.
And here, for this soft mode,
which also exists in this case,
this is actually
going to be lambda.
So you can contrast
that type of picture
with a more usual picture where
you would just have one line.
And you'd say there's
some modes up here
and some modes down there.
And you'd integrate
out these modes.
And you keep those modes.
This is a little
different because you want
to integrate out these modes.
You want to keep
both of those modes,
but they live in a little
bit of a different place.
And that's actually going to
be important to formulating
the effective theory.
So the way that you should think
about this, physically the way
you should think about it, is
that these modes are kind of
localized in that region.
This is the right
physical picture,
which requires another variable
besides just invariant mass
in order to specify that, right?
The reason we don't have to draw
a third direction for P perp
is because it was just
redundant information.
P perp squared is
always of P plus P
minus if you're talking
about fluctuations
that are near the mass shell.
For a massless mode, that mass
shell is P squared equals 0.
And so P perp would just be
providing redundant information
to our picture, and we
just can leave it out.
Now, the boundaries
of the regions
between soft and collinear here
seems like an interesting thing
to worry about.
And that is, indeed, true.
You have to think about
how you want to set up
this effective theory.
And of course, as I have
been emphasizing earlier
in the course, the
easiest way to think
about momentum
degrees of freedom
is with a Wilsonian picture.
That makes physically
what's going on very clear.
So the simplest thing
would be to introduce
a Wilsonian cut-off
and set this up
as a Wilsonian
effective field theory.
And then we would just
take these regions.
And I would literally carve
them out in the way that I drew.
I would carve out some
cut-off between them.
And I would decide who's
in the soft region, who's
in the collinear region
based on those hard cut-offs.
But we don't want to
do that, actually,
because it would mess up
all sorts of symmetries.
In particular, it would
mess up gauge cemetery
which is an important
thing when you're
talking about gauge theory.
So we're going to use
dimensional regularization,
as we have for other problems.
And that actually
will still leave us
with this picture, which
I drew as a cartoon.
You'll still be correct.
Think about the modes
live in those places
in dimensional regularization.
What's a little bit harder is
how to think about the cut-off.
And we'll treat that in
some detail later on.
So it's still the
correct picture,
but treating the region overlaps
with dimensional regularization
is a little more tricky.
But at least we can
do it in a way that
preserves the gauge invariance.
So that's going to be
our mode of operation.
This theory has a name.
It goes by the name SCET2.
That's why I called it SCET2.
We'll come back in a
moment to what SCET1 is.
So I can say that the
degrees of freedom
in this theory, the one that
we've been talking about,
are some collinear
degree of freedom that's
associated to some
direction, some collinear
degrees of freedom as well as
some soft degrees of freedom.
And when you have
effective theories that
are like this one, where the
soft and collinear degrees
of freedom live on the
same mass hyperbola,
they're called SCET2 theories.
And these are really
the kind of theories
that you get when you're
talking about energetic hadron
production.
So any questions so far?
OK, so if that's
energetic hadrons,
then SCET1 will
be energetic jets.
And that's what we'll
talk about next.
So let's do another example
which has jets in it.
And we'll see what
the similarities are
to this SCET2 set up in terms
of just identifying still what
the right degrees
of freedom are.
So let's look at e plus
e minus to two jets.
So e plus e minus collide.
They produce a
virtual photon, say.
The virtual photon produces
a quark-antiquark pair.
The quark-antiquark
pair starts to radiate.
And we get jets, two of them.
So again, there's a
kind of natural frame
to describe this scattering.
And that's the center of mass
frame of the e plus e minus.
Most e plus e minus colliders
are built in that frame.
And if you're in the
center of mass frame
and you call the for
momentum of this photon Q,
then it just has an
energy component.
So Q here is not the same as
the Q in our previous example,
but we're always going to
identify the hard scale as Q.
So here, the hard
scale is the scale
of the energy of the collision
in the center of mass frame.
And if you ask, what
does the event look
like in the center
of mass frame,
then these two jets
which are going out
have to balance each other.
And so you have two
back to back jets.
So we draw it like this, one jet
going this way, one jet going
that way.
Our original e plus e
minus might have come
in from some other direction.
So maybe e plus e minus were
coming in from here and here.
And then we have these two
jets going out this way.
Since they're jets,
that means they're
collimated sprays of radiation.
So they're not featureless.
They have some size
to them like this.
And in this process,
we can quickly
identify that there's
two relevant directions.
It's back to back,
but let's define
this direction of
this jet to be n1,
some lightlike vector that
points in that direction,
and this one to be n2.
So generically, we could
say you n is some 1, n hat.
And if we choose this
to be the z-axis,
then this must be 1, 0, 0
1, just like we had before.
But we can always pick a
lightlike vector that points
along some direction n hat.
So when I draw a
picture like this,
really what I mean when I say
n1 points in this direction
is that the hat part of it
points in that direction
in through space.
OK, so just like
before, what happens
with the jet is, as I
said last time actually,
we have a large energy flow in
this direction and a smaller
perpendicular flow.
So if we measure
perpendicular momentum, which
we can think of as perpendicular
to that axis, free axis,
then that's the perpendicular
flow inside the jet.
And so if we want to talk about
constituents inside the jet,
then we'll be interested
in smaller perpendicular
flow than flow in the
forward direction.
And that's what makes it
into a collimated jet.
You have question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
IAIN STEWART: Sure.
AUDIENCE: So you're
not using anything
about the QCD
[INAUDIBLE] to tell you
the things is [INAUDIBLE].
You're just saying we know that
we have to [INAUDIBLE] topic.
IAIN STEWART: Yeah, that's
the attitude, right.
So I mean, we'll see why.
You know, you can
ask the question,
why do we get jets
in the first place?
We haven't talked about that.
And we could talk about that.
I'm taking the attitude here,
this is what we observe.
How do we design an effective
field theory for it?
And we'll see then, from
that effective theory,
we can go back
and understand why
it is that we get
these objects and why
actually, when you
look at cross-sections,
that this is the leading order
description of what happens.
We'll come to that later.
Good question.
Any other questions?
All right.
Yeah, in the hadron case, you
just say this process exists.
And I didn't explain to you
why the process could exist.
But in the jet case,
there's more dynamics
going into the fact
that the process exists,
the fact that QCD likes
to radiate collinear
to a direction, which has to
do with the infrared structure
of the theory.
And we'll come back to that.
I mean, the short
answer, of course,
is that things like to
radiate in that direction
because there's
large logarithms that
enhance splittings that are
collinear to the direction
of motion.
And you also get smaller
coupling consonants
when you do that rather
than a wide angle emission.
So we're saying here,
what we're saying,
is we measure e plus
e minus to two jets.
If I had an extra
wide angle emission,
that would be e plus
e minus to three jets.
So I ruled that out just
right at the beginning.
OK, so what you can
do with this picture
in order to define what's
going on is you can say,
well they're to
back-to-back jets.
Let's draw a hemisphere.
So this is supposed
to be kind of out
of the board point at you.
Let's draw a hemisphere
between these two.
And then we can call one
side a and the other side b.
And we can talk
about momenta that
are flowing in the a hemisphere
and the b hemisphere.
And you see that we have
one jet in each hemisphere.
So we have a jet of
hadrons in hemisphere a.
And we have another
one in hemisphere b.
So in some ways, we can talk
about a and b independently.
So let's start off
by talking about a,
which is what I called
the n1 collinear jet.
And if we ask about
constituents in the jet,
then the perpendicular
momentum will
be of some size, which
let me just call it delta.
And that'll be much smaller than
P minus, which is of size Q.
So the energy that we
pump in through the photon
has to leave.
And the only place that it
can leave is that half of it
has to kind of leave
this direction.
Half of it has to
leave that direction
by energy conservation.
And so we have a large energy
flow in the P minus component.
And then we have a much
smaller amount in the P perp.
And that's what I already said.
And given those
two facts, you can
ask, what about the
constituents of the jet?
And again, they're collinear
because you have a hierarchy.
So the plus minus and
perpendicular momentum
of constituents would
scale in that way.
And that is Q lambda
squared 1 lambda, just as
before with a different lambda.
So here, lambda is how
much spread and perp
do we have over Q. This delta
doesn't have to be lambda QCD.
It could be something
much bigger.
Another way of thinking about
physically what this delta is
is to calculate something
called the jet mass.
So you could define the mass of
the jet as the sum of the four
vectors in hemisphere a of
all the particles squared.
And if you ask about how big
that is, in these coordinates
that we're using, it's P
plus times P minus minus P
perp squared.
If we align things so
that this thing is really
aligned with the jet, there
won't be any P perp squared.
But that wouldn't change us
scaling our given anyway.
So basically, if you ask
about what this jet mass is,
it's scaling like a P
plus times a P minus.
And it's scaling
like delta squared.
So the jet mass is something
of order delta squared.
And that's much
less than Q squared.
So another way of characterizing
that you have a jet
is to measure the invariant
mass of all the particles
in this hemisphere.
And if that invariant
mass is small relative
to the hard scale, then
it's collimated, OK?
So MJ squared Q squared
much less than 1 also
means collimated.
So we could talk about
it either in terms
of perpendicular spread,
or we could talk about it
as an invariant mass.
OK.
So this is much less than 1.
Now, with this delta, we
didn't specify what it is.
So what are possible
values of delta?
Well, let's first talk
about what it's not.
If delta was of order
Q, then obviously
we'd break the kind of scaling
that we have here that this
should be much less than 1.
And what happens in that
case is we don't have dijets.
So if either the mass MJ
squared of the particles
becomes of order Q squared
or the perpendicular spread
becomes of order Q, then we
don't have dijets anymore.
And basically, in
this case, you would
be talking about inclusive
sum over our jets
And that would be something
that you would actually
describe in a different way
in the effective field theory
because you wouldn't then have
collinear degrees of freedom
for this jet.
It's really picking
out the dijet process
that means that these
collinear degrees of freedom
are relevant.
If you did just e plus e minus
to hadrons, that's something
you could do with an
operator product expansion
without ever talking about SCET.
And that would be valid
if you were really
doing an inclusive sum
over jets in all directions
without any restrictions
that tell you it's a dijet.
And then the effect of
power counting in your OPE
would be such that
delta is of order Q.
So this is actually
the OPE region.
Let me call it the OPE region
of Peskin or any other field
theory book.
Another thing we could
do is we could take delta
to be very small.
We could take delta all
the way down to lambda QCD.
And that's also not a jet.
If delta is of order
lambda QCD, what
happens with the
spray of radiation
is that it gets
bound into a hadron.
It just can't separate.
Confinement grabs it, and you
get an energetic hadron, not
a jet.
So if the jets get too narrow,
in particular this narrow,
then the constituents
are bound into a hadron.
And that might be something
you want to talk about,
but it wouldn't be talking about
e plus e minus, the dijets.
You'd be talking about e
plus e minus to pi plus pi
minus or something.
And then you'd actually
use this other SCET
that we were talking
about a moment ago,
not the one for jets.
OK, so anything kind of in
between these two regions
much greater than lambda
QCD, much less than Q,
then we can talk about
it as being jets.
OK.
So we figure out
what region we're
interested in by figuring
out what region we're not
interested in.
So that was one jet.
And kind of by symmetry we
can talk about the other one.
So there's this one
that I called n2.
The simplest way of
invoking symmetry
is to take n1 to point
along n, which is our,
say 0, 0, minus 1.
And then just take n2 to be n
bar, which is 1, 0, 0, plus 1.
And then the description
of the n2 jet
is the same as the
description of the n1 jet.
It's just you switch
pluses and minuses.
Remember that what
defines plus and minus
depends on the
choice of this n bar.
A priori, that choice of n
bar has nothing to do with n2.
And this is just a
different physical vector.
Both n1 and n2 are physical.
And bar is an auxiliary vector.
But if I just happened
to choose that n2
is equal to that
auxiliary vector,
then it makes things simple.
Because we just have a
relation between the two
sets of degrees of freedom, this
swapping pluses and minuses.
OK.
So that's actually not
the end of the story
of the degrees of freedom here.
And that is because, even
if we make restrictions
to getting these dijets, we can
still have soft radiation that
is between the jets.
And so this one's a little
less intuitive perhaps.
So I'll call these
guys ultra soft modes.
And I'll label them
by US for Ultra Soft.
And one way of thinking about
physically what they're doing
is that they're allowing you to
communicate between the jets.
There can be radiation that's
radiated from one jet that
interferes with the other jet.
This is a homogeneous
type of radiation,
so it has the same scaling
in the plus, minus, and perp.
So this is for these
ultra soft modes.
If I compare this to the
scaling that we have for, say,
the n collinear modes--
so let me call that Pn--
that was delta squared
over Q Q delta.
And if I make the mirror
for the other jet,
then I would switch these two
delta squared over Q delta.
So when I say
communicate, what I mean
is that these guys can
talk to both of these guys
without interfering
with their scaling.
So if they're not going to
interfere with this guy's
scaling, they better have plus
momentum that's the same size.
If it was any bigger,
then we'd have a problem
because they'd interfere
with this scaling
when they tried to communicate.
And then likewise for
the minus, they better
have scaling of the same size.
And then perp is fixed.
So the word communicate here
in the way I'm defining it
means sharing momenta
of a common size--
well, means sharing momenta and
not taking the other particle
off-shell.
OK.
So we can draw a picture
for this one, too.
Like we have our SCET2 picture,
we could draw an SCET1 picture.
And that helps.
Pictures always help to make
words more palatable, more
absorbable.
So same type of picture where
you have P minus and P plus,
we also can think about
things in terms of hyperbola
of constant invariant mass.
We now have some collinear
modes for the n1 direction.
There's going to be
some purple collinear
modes for the n2 directions.
There's going to be
these soft modes.
And then we could also
have some hard modes
that we want to integrate out.
So these are the
ultra soft modes.
So the reason that I call them
ultra soft rather than soft
is because, by soft,
we meant something
that sat on the same hyperbola.
And here it sits on
a lower hyperbola,
so it should be softer.
So we call it ultra soft.
This is the hyperbola
where P squared
is of order delta squared.
This is the hyperbola where
P squared is of order delta
4 over Q squared.
If you square any
one of these guys,
you get delta 4 over Q squared.
And up here, is P
squared over Q squared.
And this kind of
thing is called SCET1.
So what does it
mean to communicate?
Well, it means that there's two
momenta that are the same size.
So the fact that I tried to
line this up as best I could,
partially succeeding, is
what I mean by communicate.
These things are the
same size in the plus.
same size in the minus.
And if we want to put in kind
of how big these things are,
we would say that.
So the scaling of
the ultra soft,
unlike the scaling
the soft, the ultra
soft in all component
scales like lambda squared.
So in terms of
scaling parameters,
we would say that
it goes like this.
And here, we're not
talking about soft.
It would have lambda
in all components.
So this is the effective
theory that turns out
to be the right one for jets.
And whenever you have
this kind of situation
where you've got collinear modes
that are living on a higher
hyperbola than the
soft modes, which
you call ultra soft modes,
that's an SCET1 type theory.
And these two actually
cover a wide range
of phenomenology, these
two particular cases, SCET1
and SCET2.
OK, questions?
We'll talk a little bit
more about this picture.
AUDIENCE: Do you think
of the soft modes
as being smaller than or
equal to lambda squared?
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
So you can ask,
now, how should I
think about drawing the blobs
around these things, right?
And you still should
think about these things
with blobs like that.
But then it becomes a
question which we didn't have,
which was kind of more obvious
actually in the SCET1 case.
And that is kind of how these
things overlap with the axes.
And we'll come back and
talk about that later.
But I think, for now,
just think of them
as being localized in that way.
In the case of the softs in
the collinear we had before,
you can think of them as
uniformly kind of coming down
into the infrared.
Here, it's not like
that because this guy
is more infrared to begin with.
And that will have
some impact later on.
OK.
So what are the
important features here?
Well, we see this
idea that I mentioned
would occur that we
have multiple modes
for the infrared.
And you can try to get
away with not doing
that, but then you would
have a lot of trouble
with your power counting.
And since power counting, as
I've convinced you hopefully
by now, is just as
important as other things
when you're designing
an effective theory,
you really don't want
to mess with that.
And so you're forced
into a situation where
you start talking about
having multiple fields
for the same degrees of
freedom because the scaling
of the momentum in different
regions of the space
you're interested in
is just different.
So the derivatives that are
corresponding to those momenta
are going to scale differently.
And if that's the
case, you're going
to need to have multiple
fields to describe
those different regions.
We'll also see the power
counting is different.
So you can ask, what
are you integrating out?
And we're still
taking the attitude
that we integrate out modes
that are off-shell and so
above a given hyperbola.
So that part of our story
of effective field theory
is really the same.
It's just that, when we
describe the low energy modes,
we need more than one of them.
So what we mean by
off-shell is the same
as it always has meant.
Off-shell modes
get integrated out.
Those are modes with large P
squared, like the hard modes.
So one natural
question when you're
talking about these
effective field theories
is, how do I know I
have all the modes?
And that's a good question.
And there's been examples
in the literature
where people wrote papers where
they didn't know all the modes
and modes were missing.
So it's not even an
academic question.
It's really a pitfall in some
sense that you can fall into.
So I take the following
attitude towards that question.
You should attack
it from all sides.
So one is that you
should really physically
think about what
the modes are doing
and have a physical
description of why
those modes are something
relevant for your effective
field theory.
After all, your
effective field theory
is supposed to be a description
of nature and infrared physics.
So there should be something
physical associated
to what those models are doing.
That's the physics side.
Calculationally,
there's various ways
that you could approach this.
So one thing you
can do, which is
sort of an order
by order thing, is
you can just calculate
results at one loop
and make sure you match
up infrared divergences.
Because if you don't match
up the infrared divergences,
then you're missing some
infrared degree of freedom
in the effective field theory.
OK.
So that's one way you
can check for the modes.
So if you can either do
physics, or you can calculate.
And when you
calculate, there's also
something called the
method of regions,
which is a nice way of thinking
about trying to discover modes,
which basically says that, any
full theory calculation I can
do, I can do that
calculation by dividing up
the integrand into regions.
And if I'm using
dimensional regularization,
then the full theory answer
is just the sum over regions.
So you can just
calculate using some EFT,
as I described to
you, and check it.
Or could do a different way.
You could say, calculate
the full theory result
with something called
the method of regions.
And that's just a
way of calculating
the full theory of
result, but it's
a way of telling you what
regions are important.
There's all-other
theorems in QCD
about what regions can
give infrared divergences.
And that's another
thing you can use.
And I won't talk about this last
one or actually about this one.
So these are different
ways that you
could look for what are the
relevant degrees of freedom.
And actually, when
we started SCET,
we didn't separate between
ultra soft and soft.
We had both of them
at the same time.
And the reason was we
knew that in some examples
we needed soft and some
examples we needed ultra soft.
And we were thinking of it
as one theory, not SCET1
and SCET2.
And then at some point, we
realized that all the examples
we were doing, as we did
more and more examples,
they broke into these
two categories, one
for jets, one for hadrons.
And so we were finding
that, for example,
if you add a soft
mode to this picture,
it just ends up being
totally irrelevant.
And you can just
absorb it or remove it.
You don't need it.
And likewise, if you tried
to put an ultra soft mode
into the example of
energetic hadrons,
you'd find you don't need it.
So you could put too many
degrees of freedom in as well.
It's not just that you
could have too few.
You could put more
than you need,
and then you would see
from your calculations
that you actually had
more than you need.
The reason I'm
spending time on this
is because this is, in some
sense, the tricky part.
Once we know what
the modes are, we'll
just get the effective
field theory and go.
AUDIENCE: Is your second
point here the method
or regions [INAUDIBLE],, is that
any different than the check it
of the first point?
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
Because, here, what I'm
saying is hypothesize
some effective field theory.
AUDIENCE: But check
it means full theory.
IAIN STEWART: And then check
it against the full theory.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
IAIN STEWART: And so
the direction here
is that you write
down something,
and you do calculations
in two theories.
And you make sure they agree.
Here, it's a little
bit different
because there may not be a
one-to-one correspondence
of the modes of the
method of regions.
Method of regions
is not technically
exactly what the
effective theory is.
So this can give you hints about
what the effective theory is.
Then you basically
go back and do this,
but it sort of helps you
because you have most
of the calculations to do this.
Yeah.
So technically, they're
a little bit different,
but they're pretty related.
OK.
So in the example
we had here, it
was a little more complicated
than our B to D pi example
because we had three
things in the infrared.
And you could ask the
question, is there something
with just one jet?
The reason we had three things
is because we had two jets.
We had the purple
jet and the pink jet.
And we can come up with a
process with only one jet.
So let me give you
a third example.
If we have something recoiling
against the jet that's
electromagnetic, like
a photon, then we
could just have one jet.
So one way of doing that
is to look at a process
like b to s gamma, where you
say that really what you want
is B to one jet plus a photon.
And that's a region
of phase space
in b to s gamma, where
the picture over there
just has one jet.
And so it's the same
picture, but now we just
have our pink jet.
So the right modes
for this picture
for this process in the region
where you just have one jet
would be like this where this is
hard and you integrate it out.
And you just have two things in
the infrared, a Cn and an ultra
soft.
In this case, you also have
to ask the question, what
is the hydronic process?
Well, it has to B meson.
What are the things
inside the B meson
that are binding it together?
And you would make those
the ultra soft modes.
So in this process
here, it's very natural
to take P squared of this lowest
line to be lambda QCD squared.
And then these guys are
binding the B meson there,
the soft modes of the B meson.
This collinear hyperbola for
the jet lives somewhere between.
And this here, in this case,
would be something of order
the B quark mass squared, OK?
So that's a little bit
different than over here
where there was kind
of a no natural--
this thing was set
by kind of what
we chose to do with the
jets was setting this.
Here, there's kind
of a natural scale
where you know
that there's going
to be some degrees of freedom.
And so it's very
natural, in this case,
to take that as an input.
And then you could
actually figure out,
given that what the jets should
be and the jets would have,
lambda QCD times Mb,
which is in the middle.
So that's kind of a natural
scaling for the b to s
gamma process, OK?
So just to give you an
idea how, if I have a jet,
it's going to look
something like this,
it might not look
exactly like that.
It depends on how
many jets you have.
And of course, these
pictures actually
get more complicated if you
try to start drawing them
when you have three jets
because then the plane
is no longer enough.
All right, so any
more questions?
OK.
So when we did HQET, the
first thing that we did
is we started to expand.
Before we designed the
effective Lagrangian,
we just said, well, what happens
if I expand the full theory?
And I'm going to take
the same attitude here.
Let's just write down
some full theory objects
and expand them in the limits
that we've been talking about.
And then we'll see what
kind of effective theory
we want based on the results
from those expansions.
So let's start with spinners
in a collinear limit.
So let me start with some
massless QCD spinners
in the Dirac representation.
We could use some
other representation,
but let's just use Dirac.
So we have spinners
for the quarks.
We have spinners for
the antiquarks, V,
where this curly
V and this curly U
are two-component objects.
I'll make sure it
looks curly enough.
So what we can do
here is we can expand.
And you see that what
happens when you expand
is that you can think about
the P3 vector being larger
than P1 and P2.
So let's just let our n be
1, 0, 0, 1 and our n bar
be 1, 0, 0, minus 1.
So they're back to
back with each other.
Whether I put the plus
or minus 1 there or there
doesn't really matter.
Let's expand in n bar
dot P, which in this case
is P0 plus P3 being much greater
than P perp, just P1 and P2.
And then that's
much greater than n
dot P, which is P0 minus P3.
And what that means is that
you can approximate sigma dot P
over P0 from these
massless particles.
It's just sigma 3 because
you pick out the P3.
That's the big component.
The P1 and P2, you can drop.
Then it kicks out the sigma 3.
And then P3 is also
the same size as P0,
so you're just getting sigma 3.
So what you get
from this then would
be guys that look like this.
Just so, I put it in
the two possibilities
for the curly U are
four-component spinners that
look like this for U and
then likewise for V of P.
We can work out what we get.
We get that.
So this is actually a
little different than HQET.
In HQET, what you
would have found
is that the antiquarks would
have been just left out.
And the quarks would've
been there in the theory.
Here, both of them survive.
And actually two
degrees of freedom
survive for both the particles
and the antiparticles.
So it's not like
we're integrating out
of something like the
antiparticle, like in HQET.
By this expansion, we
still have all four
of these degrees of freedom if
you count degrees of freedom
by whether you have particles,
antiparticles, and spin states.
Nevertheless, there is a
simplification that occurs.
And that is the fact that
the spinners that you have
have a projection relation.
So if you look in
this basis that we're
talking about here, what n
slash is if you write down
what the gamma matrices are
in the Dirac representation,
then n slash is this.
And another useful
thing is n slash n bar
slash over 4, which you
can work out as just this.
And these spinners here,
which I need a name for--
so let's call this
Un and call this Vn.
They satisfy n slash
Un is n slash Vn is 0.
And they also satisfy
n slash n bar slash
Un is Un for both of them.
So what we can do with
that is the following.
We can take the identity
in this 4 by 4 space.
And we can actually
write it as n
slash n bar slash over 4 plus
n bar slash n slash over 4.
And that's because,
remember, that gamma mu
gamma nu plus 2 g mu nu
and n dot n bar is 2.
So this is just one
way of using those.
This is the anticommutator
dotted into n and n bar.
So I can write it out that way.
And this kind of formula
here is the formula
that is for projection
operators, right?
So as you act with the operator,
you get that guy back again.
So you could act twice
with that operator.
And so what you can
do with this one
is you could let one
act on psi of QCD.
And if you did that, you'd get
n slash n bar slash over 4 psi
plus n bar slash n
slash over 4 psi.
And you could define
these two pieces
as being two different
components of the full theory
field that I'll
call Cn and psi n.
And what happens
at high energies,
because of the type of thing
we were doing over there,
is that we only like
to produce Cn's.
We don't like to
produce psi n bars.
So if you look at some
high energy process,
this sort of thing I was
doing at the spinners
basically boils down
to one sentence.
And that is that we
produce or annihilate
the components,
the guys that live
in this Cn, not the so-called
small components, which
live in this other guy.
This language of calling
them the small components
is something that goes back to
the early days of QCD actually.
We may say that
word a few times,
but the history won't
be so important to us.
OK, so, so much
for the spinners.
There is some simplification
in the spinners
because we do like to
produce certain combinations.
But it didn't really teach
us too much beyond that.
And we didn't see that we
lost a degree of freedom
like we did in HQET.
But nevertheless, there
was some simplification.
Let's do the same thing for
the propagator of the quarks.
Take the propagator of the full
theory, expand in this limit.
So first of all,
propagators always
involve P squared plus i0.
In our decomposition,
that's in n bar
dot P n dot P plus Minkowski
P perp squared plus i0.
And if you look at the
size of these things,
they're all the same size.
This guy is lambda 0, and
this guy is lambda squared.
And this guy is just
lambda squared by itself.
So the two guys
are the same size,
although they become the same
size for different regions.
This is lambda 1
squared if you like.
So I don't drop anything
in that propagator.
And you see that actually
that's not entirely true.
And it does depend on
what type of things
you're interacting with.
But if I just have P's that are
collinear, as I've drawn here,
then there's nothing to drop.
So if you look at fermions
that are collinear
and you look at i P slash
over P squared plus i0,
you can decompose P slash
out in terms of n slash
and n bar slash,
write it out in terms
of the coordinates we're using.
And then in the numerator,
you keep the full denominator.
But in the numerator, there
is one momentum component
that's larger than the others.
And that is the n bar dot P
piece, which is order one.
So there is a simplification
of the P slash.
And it's related in some
ways to the simplification
of the spinners.
If you take two of these guys
and you do the sum over spin,
you'll actually get n
slash over 2 n bar dot P.
AUDIENCE: Is it n slash
on the side of the 0?
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
IAIN STEWART: So the right way
of thinking about the numerator
here is that, if you do the
sum over spins of sort of two
of these spinners,
like this, that's
giving you the numerator.
And if you look at sort
of the overlap of this,
if you look at any
amplitude, you also
have to take into account,
but I haven't written yet--
which is this.
And that's going to
go like n bar slash.
So what happens is you
have n slash, n bar slash.
And that gives
you the projector,
which then overlaps
order 1 with the spinner.
Yeah.
But that's a good question.
Later-- but that's a good point.
OK.
So we can ask about, if we have
some propagator for a fermion,
then what does it look like?
And you can take that
first order term,
and we can write it in a way
that kind of is reminiscent
of something more like
NRQCD or this nucleon theory
or even HQET.
It's just another way of
writing the same formula that
is sometimes useful.
We just divide through
by the n bar dot P.
And then it's n dot P plus
P perp squared over n bar
dot P. And then there's the
i0, but the sign of the i0
will depend on the sign
of the n bar dot P.
The fact that this could
be both plus i0 or minus i0
is the same thing as saying
that there's antiparticles
and particles in the theory.
If it was just plus
i0, as it was in HQET,
we only had the particles.
Here, it could be either sign.
We have both.
And so this thing,
again, has both particles
and antiparticles, which
we saw when we were
doing the spinners as well.
And if we want to think about
particles and antiparticles
separately, then we could have
a definite sign for the i0's.
But if we want to think about
them in a combined propagator,
then we have to
write it this way.
All right, so once we know
what the propagator is,
then we can also figure
out what the power counting
of the fields are because
the propagator tells us
what the kinetic term should
look like of the Lagrangian.
So let me show you
how that works.
So where does the
propagator come from?
The propagator comes
from the time order
product of two fields.
And in this case, it comes
from the time order product
of a field for this Cn component
that we were talking about.
And if we just take the
free kinetic term, which
is the Lagrangian that
we'd give that propagator,
that's enough to determine
the power counting for fields,
as is always the case in
any effective field theory.
So we haven't figured out
what the Lagrangian is,
but we know something about
what it's going to look like.
So let me write
down enough of that
to determine for you what the
power counting would look like.
So when I read it this
way, as I wrote it,
where it's linear in
this n dot P derivative,
you know that what that's
going to correspond to
in the Lagrangian is
some n dot partial.
And I have to have
an n bar slash here
because that always comes
along with an n decomposing
the metric.
If you ask about the
power counting here,
well, d4x has all
4 components of k.
And x is the inverse of k.
So the way that you
assign a power counting
for x is that you say the
phase should be of order 1.
So the scaling for x
is the opposite of k.
So that fixes that d4x should
be lambda to the minus 4.
So x plus times k minus
is of order 1, et cetera.
And that tells you
how many powers
to associate with the d4x.
We know how many powers to
associate with this partial
because that was our momentum.
That's lambda squared.
And actually, the
other terms here
will also be lambda squared.
And then we just
say, well, that's let
the power counting in this field
be arbitrary lambda to the a.
And so if we do that, then
we get an overall scaling
for this Lagrangian that's
lambda to the 2a minus 2.
2 to the power of the lambda
minus 4 cancel by the partial n
dot partial and we get that.
Now, the way that we do
effective field theory is we
look at the lowest order
term, and we count everything
relative to that.
So what we do is we say, we
want the lowest order Lagrangian
to scale like lambda to the 0.
And you can think of
that roughly in a power
counting sense as normalizing
the free kinetic term
or normalizing the
kinetic term in general.
And then, once you
do that, then you
fix what the
scaling of the field
is, Cn to the order lambda.
And that's different
than the mass dimension.
So I said that we
were going to be
doing a power counting
that's different
than the mass dimension.
If we looked at the mass
dimension of this field,
Cn would have mass dimension
that's 3/2, whereas it has,
if you like, a lambda power
counting dimension which is 1.
So if I look for the
powers of lambda, that's 1.
And that was one of the things
I told you was going to happen
is that, in this
effective theory,
we wouldn't just be
counting mass dimension.
We'd be counting something else.
OK.
So that's collinear quarks.
We can do a similar thing
for collinear gluons.
And we may not get to the
end of that discussion today,
but let's start it.
The momenta for
a collinear gluon
scales the same as the
momenta for a collinear quark.
That means collinear
doesn't distinguish
between quarks and gluons.
So P squared, the
full P squared,
is still something that we're
going to leave together.
And let's just consider
looking at the propagator
in a general covariant
gauge and asking
kind of the same type of
thing that we did over here
about the scaling of the field.
So the propagator for
two collinear gluons
and the general
covariant gauge--
time order product vacuum
matrix element of two fields.
Ignore the subscript
ends right now.
I'm just writing down
a full theory result.
We called C something
else, so we better
not make that gauge parameter.
So let me call the
gauge parameter tau.
That's the gauge parameter of
the general covariant gauge.
And this is a full three result.
The thing that
makes it collinear
is if we say that k has
a collinear scaling.
So as above, k squared is k plus
k minus plus k perp squared.
That's of order lambda
squared, and there's
no expansion in there.
And there's two k squareds here.
There's one there,
and there's one there.
And if you start looking
at g mu nu minus k mu k nu
over k squared, you also
find that the terms there
are the same size.
So there's actually--
let's see how that works.
So let's do an example of that.
So g perp you knew was just 1.
So that's obviously something
that has no scaling.
And if you compare that to
k perp mu k perp nu over k
squared, k perp
scale like lambda. k
squared scales like
lambda squared.
So this is lambda squared
over lambda squared.
So that's also lambda to the 0.
So both the g perp mu nu
and the k perp nu term
are the same size.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: If it happened
that it didn't work out,
could you choose the gauge
parameter have a [INAUDIBLE]
with lambda?
IAIN STEWART: You
could, but then you'd
be restricted to
the classic gauges
that you would be able to
use in the effective theory.
And then you have to ask what
gauge invariance would mean.
If I don't make any
restrictions on tau,
I don't assign a
power counting to it,
that means my effective theory
should allow all these gauges.
And I actually want that.
That's a good question.
You can do the same
thing looking at,
for example, g plus g minus.
That's also 1, so lambda 0.
Then you get k plus k
minus over k squared.
That's also lambda squared
over lambda squared.
So this is what I was
saying, that the two
terms are the same size.
If you dot in n mu n nu,
that kills the g mu nu.
g plus plus is 0.
And then you just
get k plus squared
over k squared, which
is lambda to the 1/4
over lambda squared,
which is lambda squared.
So when the g mu nu is not
1, then the k mu k nu term
can still determine
how big something is.
And that's what would happen
for these off-diagonal terms.
So if we go through the
same type of exercise
that we did for the fermion,
d4x scales like 1 over k
to the fourth.
So that's lambda to the
minus 4, just as before.
And actually, if we were
to do the following,
if we were to write this as--
I should have done
that up there.
If we were to write
it as minus i over k
to the fourth k squared g
mu nu minus tau k mu k nu,
the k to the fourth just
matches up with the d4x.
So those take care
of each other.
And then the fields here have
to match up with the rest.
So the scaling of this should
be the scaling of the A mu A nu.
And that basically means
that A mu in A nu scale
like a momenta.
So A mu n for this collinear
gluon scales like k mu, scales
like lambda squared 1 lambda.
Let me write that one more time.
And that's also a nice
thing because it also
means you could form a
covariate derivative that's
homogeneous by
combining together,
if I write it this
way, k mu and g A mu.
I can get a covariant derivative
where, for each component of k,
I also have a component
of the gauge field
that's the same size.
So you could have
argued it, originally
just from gauge invariance, that
you want to sort of have fields
that are of the same
size as your momenta,
but we did it a little
bit differently here.
So it's nice that
that comes out.
This all hangs together.
So next time, we'll
talk about the fact
that what does it mean that the
gauge field has components that
are scaling in a different way.
And particularly, there's a
component of the gauge field
that's order 1.
There's no power suppression
for that component.
And we'll talk about what
implications that has.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So what about in the
non-variant case, like n bar
of A equals 0?
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
So you could go through this
argument in that gauge as well,
and it will work.
AUDIENCE: But you have n
bar to the A equals 0, so--
IAIN STEWART: Yeah, that's fine.
That's just a
restriction on the-- you
can still assign
a scaling to it.
And a special choice if it is 0.
Scaling and values of things
are not the same thing, right?
Like, you could have a field
that scales like 1 in the power
company, but happens to be 0.
And that's OK.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I had a question
about SCET1 and SCET2.
IAIN STEWART: Sure.
AUDIENCE: So in the example
adding one jab, and one hadron,
like the [INAUDIBLE],,
why do I need
to have different degrees
of freedom to describe
[INAUDIBLE]?
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
It's really because
of the way the modes
sat on those hyperbolas that,
in the case of the hadrons,
you had the soft
modes and collinear
modes on the same hyperbola.
And that's going to change how
the effective theory looks.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
But from a physically point
of view, why the hadrons--
[INAUDIBLE] the hadrons
behaving in a different way
than [INAUDIBLE]?
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
So one way of
thinking about it is,
if you just had the
collinear modes alone
and you didn't have
the soft modes,
then it would be very similar.
It would just be that
the hyperbola moved down.
And you think maybe those
two theories are the same.
There's examples
of that actually.
There's one example
that we'll cover where
you don't need soft modes.
And then you can't really
tell whether you're
using SCET1 or SCET2.
But if you have a process that
has both soft and collinear
modes, then it's the kind
of way that those modes
talk to each other
that distinguishes
the cases of hadrons
and jets in the cases--
AUDIENCE: For example,
for the case of the jet,
[INAUDIBLE] soft modes
like as a need for the--
IAIN STEWART: Right.
You could try, yes.
And it turns out that those
modes aren't relevant.
So you have to be a
little bit faithful
from what I've told you so far.
AUDIENCE: But there is no
physical picture for why
it can understand [INAUDIBLE].
IAIN STEWART: You
can understand it
because what would happen
with those soft modes is
that they would take the
collinear modes far off-shell.
If you just had one of
those soft modes interacting
with the collinear mode, you end
up not with the collinear mode
back again, but something that's
further off-shell that you
actually want to integrate out.
So that thing that has the
scaling that allows you to just
have collinear mode in something
which we call ultra soft in
and still have collinear,
that's the ultra soft mode.
So if you want to
communicate with the jet
without disturbing it
and blowing it apart,
then you really need
the ultra soft mode.
Yeah.
But these are all
good questions,
and we'll talk
much more about it.